job interviews Redis so nervous
well hey we are the final two so hey you
have a 50-50 shot that's a pretty good
chance good job
I know that oh yeah that's me I'm sorry
steps tell you this but we decided to go
in a different direction you didn't get
the job I can provide you excellent
resource
hello I am I live oh thank you again
furball oh hey ah how's it go
got the job yeah my god yeah he just
decided to give me the job on the spot I
was really good in there are you Wow I
would just go home don't even worry
about it
I think I should still go and I would
not I wouldn't do that if I were you I
mean I just did drive all the way down
you know what I just realized I forgot
my phone in there I'm gonna go grab that
I'll be right back just stay there look
I will do whatever it takes to get this
job Israelis please I am begging you I
need this job I need it you don't
understand yet I've got some people
to me there I said it mr. rabbit Fred no
hey what happened in there oh the
benefits uh we were just talking about
all the great health care options I have
and finally get that LASIK eye surgery
oven running I was just picking up the
vibe from him you should just go home if
I think it's worth a shot I'm just gonna
go know what we forgot we were talking
about a tee time golf I forgot I forgot
the number it was 925 or 1025 I can take
it
be right back stay there I'm giving you
one more shot and I'm giving you one
more shot
you don't expand how much I need this
job know how much I need this job you
everybody you want a higher hand you
wanna hire him it looks like you got
drunk
that's not sniffing for this leg in that
sniff each other you and I are druggie
over me are you kidding me let's do
something wild right now okay okay
give me the job hi I've got a new hiring
no give me a yeah it's gonna cost a
charity for Evans hey what the hell man
I just made partner
I heard you slandering me in there I was
trying to get you a job in there by
saying that I do drugs I did not do that
I just think you need to go man
just you know what I think you're trying
to get me to leave so you get the job by
default that is no securities here
that's not what's going on I'm oh look
at this this is so funny
this is Oh what they do to the new guy
just hazing the new guy I don't see you
guys Monday because I definitely got the
job